- But I gotta tell you
this, 'cause I was like,
"Oh my God, he's gonna do "The Dance",
so I'm going through a divorce
and there's been a lot
of, I don't know, books
and people always give you stuff to help,
especially when you have kids and stuff
and I know that you've
been divorced as well
and it was like, man, there's
so much shame and guilt
and everybody kind of sends
you stuff and I was like,
I was just kind of working through it.
And I couldn't quite
nail down the feeling,
I was like, you don't want to crap on it,
like you don't want to say,
that didn't count or matter.
But you don't know what to put in it,
'cause it didn't work out how you wanted.
And so, anyway, I kid you not,
I was listening to my playlist
and "The Dance" came on.
And I was like, no that's the thing.
- That's it.
So I literally, it's not like
your song, like a rip off,
but I literally wrote this whole thing,
like therapeutically for me
and it's actually on my next album
and it's the whole kind of, come around.
Like the little tag part is
♪ Even though my heart is broken ♪
♪ It was worth the dance anyway ♪
And it's like this whole
thing but I was like,
I think what's interesting about it
is I sang that song from childhood
and it never hit me.
- That's a great song right there.
- Oh my God.
- That's a character of a great song.
- And it hit me, I was
literally bawling in my own room
I was like, I mean it was not so bad!
It was worth it!
And I literally was like,
because it is true, I
think a lot of people
that go through such a devastating,
there's a lot of grief
with it, a lot of loss.
And a lot of change, especially with kids.
It was one of those things,
like all the books were helpful,
but it's so funny I guess
because I'm a musician,
but I was listening in my
room and I was just like,
(sobs) and I was listening to "The Dance"
and that's like the one hook of it,
but it was like the whole
point, I got the point.
And I think sometimes that's so crazy,
like you don't know that's gonna happen.
And you're like, you've known
this song your entire life
and you freak out when it
actually is a direct impact.